[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit heinz
wolf uns marietta slomka
guten abend ein letztes wahlkampf
wochenende steht uns bevor die
kandidierenden hetzen weiter von
auftritt zu auftritt kann man noch etwas
drehen noch zulegen einfach ist das
nicht viele briefwähler haben ihr kreuz
de schon gemacht andererseits gibt es
noch viele unentschlossene die sich noch
nicht ganz sicher sind vielleicht sogar
erst spontan in der wahlkabine
entscheiden die momentane stimmungslage
sieht laut neuen zdf-politbarometer so
aus die cdu käme auf 22 prozent die spd
auf 25
afd läge bei 11 genau wie die fdp die
linke bei 6 alle unverändert zur
vorwoche die grünen würden einen punkt
verlieren auf 16 prozent aus sicht von
armin laschet ist das noch nicht die
trendwende auf die seine partei hofft
und für die er auch heute weiter captain
beobachtungen dazu von mathis feldhoff
armin laschet kämpft für sich und für
die union heute in augsburg
der kanzlerkandidat hat sich verändert
in den letzten wochen seine frühere
zurückhaltung ist einem kampfgeist
gewichen einem kampfgeist der sogar die
csu inzwischen beeindruckt als seine
rede am nachmittag von klimaaktivisten
unterbrochen wird macht er daraus eine
attacke auf die grünen und ihre
regierungszeit in nrw das kommt an
deshalb lasse ich mir von grünen nicht
sagen dass sie was für klimapolitik tun
immer wenn sie regieren waren sie für
braunkohle und jetzt ist die verzerrte
andere weise der beginn seiner
kandidatur war eine einzige katastrophe
der machtkampf mit söder im streit
entschieden die folge eine sticheln de
csu
schlafwagen wahlkampf kandidat der
herzen der antreiber söder lässt kaum
etwas aus und nimmt dabei die sinkenden
umfragen in kauf
laschet lacht den konflikt einfach weg
fünf monate später präsentieren sie sich
heute als du als wäre nie etwas gewesen
harmonie fast zum fremdschämen
das ist genau das richtige stadt
entspricht die zahlen sind zwar immer
noch nicht viel besser aber sie sinken
immerhin nicht weiter das veranlasst
manchen der laschet offenbar schon mal
aufgegeben hatte sich zu korrigieren
ich weiß dass ich da etwas war wieder
etwas besorgt war habe ich bin seit
einigen tagen doch sicher dass wir am
nächsten sonntag stärkste fraktion im
deutschen bundestag sein werden und noch
eine fatale fehleinschätzung ist der
union offenbar unterlaufen allein die
anwesenheit von angela merkel sollte auf
laschet ausstrahlen ihr auftritt zum
wahlkampfauftakt schien ihr genug denn
so recht helfen wollte merkel zunächst
gar nicht
anders vorgänger die ihre politische
arbeit beenden sollten sich zurücknehmen
das ist meine haltung meine feste
überzeugung alles hat seine zeit
16 jahre lang hat die union von einem
merkel faktor gelebt das nicht beachtet
zu haben ist für den ehemaligen
strategiechef der cdu ein kardinalfehler
was aber niemand von uns wusste ist wie
hoch ist dieser merkel faktor und jetzt
stellen wir fest dass dieser merkel
faktor offensichtlich sehr sehr großes
das zu viel zurückhaltung allerdings
armin laschet nicht auf den kanzler
stuhl bringt sondern eher auf die
oppositionsbank muss auch angela merkel
einsehen jetzt die kehrtwende
allein in der letzten woche gibt es
gleich mehrere auftritte mit ihrem
kandidaten
an seinem tag in bayern unterstützt
laschet vor allem junge csu-abgeordnete
abgeordnete die nicht nur heute loben
ich schätze an ihm sehr dass er jemand
ist der zuhört der auf die menschen
zugeht der abwägt bevor er etwas sagt
der auch standhaft ist wenn der wind ihn
frontal ins gesicht bläst lasche
zweikampf gleicht einer achterbahnfahrt
ob es jetzt nochmal nach oben geht oder
ob es nur die schlussgerade ist die
nicht mehr ansteigt sieht der kandidat
in neun tagen
die wahlberechtigten in der hauptstadt
werden am übernächsten sonntag in den
wahlkampf gehen wird ziemlich lange
brauchen weil so viel anzukreuzen ist
neben der bundestagswahl ist in berlin
auch noch wahl zum abgeordnetenhaus die
entscheidet wer das amt des regierenden
bürgermeisters oder bürgermeisterin
bekleidet außerdem sind noch bezirks
wahlen und da wird es nicht langweilig
wird gibt es zusätzlich noch einen
volksentscheid ob große
wohnungsunternehmen enteignet werden
soll das wohnungs thema ist im berliner
wahlkampf eines der wichtigsten stephan
haselberger berichtet
immer wieder demonstrieren sie gegen
hohe mieten und die wohnungsnot in
berlin große konzerne wie deutsche
wohnen sollen enteignet werden fordern
einige auch darüber stimmen die berliner
bei den abgeordnetenhauswahlen in einem
volksentscheid ab
14.700 50 wohnungen hat berlin heute von
deutsche wohnen und wo novia gekauft für
2,4 milliarden euro die spd hat den deal
eingefädelt die politische botschaft
dahinter kaufen ist besser als enteignen
sie will mieten und wohnen zur chefin
sache machen franziska giffey
familienministerin bis zum aberkannten
doktortitel und trotzdem favoritin auf
den bürgermeisterposten hier besucht die
sozialdemokraten ein neues stadtquartier
wo auch 25% sozialwohnungen entstehen
sie will den neubau forcieren
enteignungen sind für sie eine rote
linie wir setzen eben nicht auf
enteignung sondern darauf dass wir auf
partnerschaftlicher basis gemeinsam mit
städtischen mit genossenschaften und mit
privaten wohnungsbau unternehmen einen
plan für diese stadt entwickeln damit
wir in diesen nächsten zehn jahren
200.000 wohnungen bauen können das rote
rathaus als erste grüne erobern das ist
der plan von bettina jarasch die
momentan hinter gitter liegt anders als
giffey sagt sie offen mit wem sie
regieren will spd und linken sie schlägt
an den mieten schutzschirm vor
enteignungen leben sie eigentlich ab
wird aber trotzdem dafür stimmen ich
glaube dass es den druck braucht damit
genügend wohnungsunternehmen tatsächlich
auch sich mit uns einen tisch setzen und
sich auch wirklich bewegen bei diesen
verhandlungen aber mein angebot steht
wenn wir diesen pakt gemeinsam
geschmiedet kriegen dann ist die
vergesellschaftung vom tisch kai wegner
spitzenkandidat der cdu in umfragen
zurzeit auf platz drei er wittert
wechselstimmung sieht große
schnittmengen mit der spd auch er will
mehr bauen und ist gegen enteignungen
bei vergesellschaftung nichts bringt wer
es kostet wahnsinnig viel geld und
schafft keine einzige neue wohnung und
das problem dass wir in berlin haben ist
dass wir zu wenig wohnungen haben ich
will keine mangelwirtschaft sondern ich
will das problem beseitigen das sieht
sebastian czaja von der fdp genauso
enteignung ist der weg der hier in der
stadt zu einem sehr angespannten klima
führt der auch nicht das problem lösen
wird weil wir brauchen 200.000 neue
wohnungen und nicht 200.000 wohnungen
bei denen der eigentümer wechselt auch
christian brink sfd hält nichts von
enteignungen und mieten regulierung
einmieten regulierung bringt uns gar
nichts weil es schafft keine a und b
werden durch neben regulierungen
investoren komplett vergrault klaus
lederer amtierende kultursenator im rot
rot grünen senat und spitzenkandidat der
linken ist für enteignungen und trotzdem
weiter offen für eine koalition mit der
spd wenn ein volksentscheid sich dafür
ausspricht dass dieser in berlin diese
anstrengungen unternehmen soll dann gehe
ich davon aus dass jede regierung
erstmal grundsätzlich er sich an das
ergebnis des volksentscheids gebunden
fühlt ich finde das ist eine
urdemokratische veranstaltung da muss
man jetzt gar keine rote linien aufmalen
spekulation hohe preise verdrängen die
angst geht um in den kiezen berlin
braucht dringend lösungen ein
dreierbündnis wird die nach der wahl
wohl suchen müssen rot-grün-rot
deutschland ampel jamaika zumindest
rechnerisch sind diese koalitionen
möglich
dass es wohl so viele
koalitionsmöglichkeiten geben wird zeigt
unser politbarometer extra für berlin
wenn schon jetzt am sonntag wahl zum
berliner abgeordnetenhaus wäre käme die
spd auf 21 prozent die cdu auf 17 beide
fast so wie bei der letzten landtagswahl
die grünen könnten dazu gewinnen und kam
auf 20 prozent die linke würde hingegen
verlieren und läge bei 12 die fdp käme
auf 9 prozent deutlich weniger als bei
der letzten berlin wahl die fdp läge bei
auch ein bisschen mehr als beim letzten
mal und 13 punkte 13 prozent entfielen
auf die anderen parteien was in der
summe ziemlich viel ist gut möglich dass
die ein oder andere kleine partei neu
ins abgeordnetenhaus halt sieht
nicht nur in berlin auch in mecklenburg
vorpommern gibt es zeitgleich zur
bundestagswahl noch eine landtagswahl im
moment regiert dort ja
spd-ministerpräsidentin manuela schwesig
mit einer großen koalition wobei groß
eigentlich kein so ganz passender
begriff ist die cdu lag schon bei der
letzten landtagswahl nur auf platz drei
und so sehen die aktuellen zahlen des
politbarometers für mecklenburg
vorpommern aus die spd käme auf 38
prozent die afg auf 17 die cdu müsste
sich mit 15 prozent begnügen die linke
käme auf fdp und grüne wegen gleichauf
mit jeweils sechs prozent
auch wenn umfragen ja immer nur
momentaufnahmen sind und dass noch viele
unentschlossene gibt manuela schwesig
kann sich also ziemlich sicher sein dass
sie ministerpräsidentin bleibt bernd
mosebach berichtet die
ministerpräsidentin war schon dagegen
nachmittag schaut auch michael sack
vorbei ein muss für wahlkämpfende
politiker die alljährliche
mecklenburgische
landwirtschaftsausstellung
treffpunkt für aussteller und landwirte
eigentlich klassische cdu wählerschaft
nicht so im nordosten
galgenhumor im kuhstall
15 prozent der wahlberechtigten so das
aktuelle politbarometer würden den
spitzenkandidaten der cdu wählen seit
einem jahr ist der landrat aus
vorpommern landesvorsitzender seiner
partei
landespolitische erfahrung hatte nicht
manuela schwesig regiert seit vier
jahren als ministerpräsidentin gemeinsam
mit der cdu aus berlin war die damalige
bundesfamilienministerin gekommen um von
ihrem erkrankten vorgänger das amt zu
übernehmen
mit 38 prozent im politbarometer könnte
sie wieder mit der cdu koalieren aber
auch mit anderen parteien mit einer
ausnahme
zur verfügung mit allen anderen
demokratischen fraktionen zu sprechen
aber ich sage ganz klar im wahlkampf
geht es nicht um koalitionen sondern
geht es darum wer die stärkste
politische kraft wird und wir wissen aus
den umfragen dass die menschen sich ganz
vorne die spd wünschen die krise hat sie
auch als chance verstanden profil zu
gewinnen der koalitionspartner cdu stand
dabei nicht selten eher im schatten es
geht hier nicht nur darum die dinge
schön zu verkaufen sondern es geht darum
die arbeit zu machen und wenn ich mir
diese pandemie als beispiel anschaue so
ist das ministerium was im wesentlichen
die arbeit geleistet hat dass wirtschaft
und gesundheitsministerium ein cdu
geführt ist wir haben es nur nicht laut
genug verkauft die afg zog in den
letzten landtag auf anhieb mit fast 21
prozent liegt aktuell bei 17 kann
offenbar von der schwäche der cdu bisher
nicht profitieren die landtagsfraktion
hatte nach heftigem streit mehrere
mitglieder verloren der landesverband
gilt als zerstritten es ist doch klar
dass das denn wenn leute sozusagen
unzufrieden sind sie dann auch laut
werden das geht natürlich nicht im sinne
unserer partei unter reagieren wir dann
als landesvorstand auch auf diese dinge
daraus kann man aber keine allgemeine
zerstrittenheit der partei ableiten als
sicher kann gelten dass die linkspartei
im nächsten springer landtag vertreten
sein wird die grünen seit 2016 draußen
könnten wieder drin sein ebenso die fdp
sei 2011 nicht mehr vertreten
wer hier einzieht oder besser bleibt
scheint klar in der staatskanzlei für
unser 23 jahren sozialdemokraten die
regierungsgeschäfte manuela schwesig hat
gute chancen dass das auch die nächsten
fünf jahre so bleibt
am ende der sendung gibt es das
politbarometer dann noch ganz
ausführlich und sie können alle
ergebnisse und zahlen aber natürlich
auch online abrufen auf zdf
und jetzt macht erstmals wolf weiter im
fall der mutmaßlichen
anschlagspläne auf die hagener synagoge
muss der festgenommene 16 jährige in
untersuchungshaft
das hat ein haftrichter das hagener
amtsgerichts entschieden teilte die
generalstaatsanwaltschaft düsseldorf mit
es bestehe der dringende tatverdacht der
vorbereitung einer schweren
staatsgefährdenden gewalttat
am mittwoch hatte die polizei den
bereich um die synagoge nach hinweisen
auf eine mögliche gefährdung lage
weiträumig abgesperrt und gesichert
die machtübernahme der taliban in kabul
hatte im august zu einem der
gefährlichsten einsätze der bundeswehr
geführt heute würdigt der
bundespräsident steinmeier die leistung
der an der evakuierungs mission
beteiligten und zeichnete den kommandeur
dieses bundeswehreinsatzes
brigadegeneral jüngst mit dem
bundesverdienstkreuz aus
wir würdigen ein einsatz
der den beteiligten viel abverlangt hat
mehr als sich die meisten menschen
vorstellen können
es war ein einsatz dessen wohl und wehe
unser ganzes land für zwei wochen in
atem hielt
dieser einsatz war notwendig er hat
menschenleben gerettet
das pentagon hat fehler bei einem
militärschlag in der afghanischen
hauptstadt kabul ende august eingeräumt
bei einem drohnenangriff seien nicht wie
beabsichtigt kämpfer der
terrororganisation ging es sondern
versehentlich zivilisten getötet worden
general frank mackenzie nannte den
angriff einen tragischen fehler bis zu
zehn menschen waren dabei ums leben
gekommen darunter auch kinder
italien führt als erstes land in europa
einen verpflichtenden 3g nachweis den
sogenannten green pass in der gesamten
arbeitswelt ein ab dem 15 oktober müssen
alle beschäftigten nachweisen ob sie
geimpft genesen oder getestet worden
sind wer sich weigert wird nach fünf
tagen von der arbeit suspendiert und
bezieht kein gehalt mehr italien will
damit die infektionszahlen senken und
die impfbereitschaft erhöhen
in wien hat der erste prozess um den
corona ausbruch im österreichischen
skiort ischgl begonnen angehörige eines
an cupid 19 gestorbenen österreichers
waren vor gericht gezogen
die kläger werfen dem staat vor der mann
habe sich bei der chaotisch
organisierten abreise aus ischgl im
frühjahr 2020 mit dem ansteckenden virus
infiziert und seine hinterbliebenen
fordern nun 100.000 euro schadensersatz
in russland hat die parlamentswahl
begonnen sie dauert bis einschließlich
sonntag oppositionelle haben in den
monaten vor der wahl immer wieder
beklagt es gebe staatliche repressionen
präsident putin rief per video botschaft
zur stimmabgabe auf die bei gilt als
wichtiger stimmungstest für ihn die
kreml partei geeintes russland will ihre
absolute mehrheit in der duma
verteidigen
die pogrome in hoyerswerda und rostock
lichtenhagen die brandanschläge von
mölln und solingen die nsu morde die
anschläge in halle und hanno die liste
rechter gewalt ließe sich noch lange
fortsetzen
die ausschreitungen in hoyerswerda 1991
kurz nach der wiedervereinigung bildeten
sozusagen den auftakt besonders
schockierte damals dass da keine
einzeltäter oder nur einzelne gruppen
agierten sondern dass das in neuer serie
und später auch rostock regelrechte
pogrome fahren ein mob aus hunderten die
ohne jede scham und verlaufenden kameras
migranten bedrohten fast eine woche lang
ging das so viele opfer waren ddr
vertragsarbeiter etwa aus vietnam oder
mosambik den ehemaligen sozialistischen
bruderländern
thomas bärsch und franziska wunderlich
über die ereignisse vor 30 jahren
thorsten robering seit einem jahr die
geschicke von hoyerswerda in sachsen und
empfängt heute gäste aus rostock mölln
und solingen städte die ein dunkler
fleck in ihrer geschichte ein auf dem
hof hoyerswerda auslasten heftige
fremdenfeindlicher ausschreitungen die
genau heute vor 30 jahren ihren anfang
nahmen und eine woche dauern soll hat
eine stadt überhaupt eine chance sogar
vier mal wieder loszuwerden da sage ich
ganz drastisch aus meiner sicht nein
weil es ist ein teil der geschichte der
stadt wenn ich ein teil einer geschichte
bin in meiner stadt ich kann ja nicht
meine geschichte loswerden sondern es
geht darum wie geht die stadt damit und
mit seiner geschichte und wenn ich offen
zu meiner geschichte mit meiner
geschichte lebe und damit umgehe wenn es
das der richtige weg es sind diese
aufnahmen die das bild der stadt drei
jahrzehnte lang prägen sollte er ist
belagern dutzende später hunderte
rechtsextreme ausländer unterkünfte und
greifen sie an in den unterkünften leben
asylbewerber oder vertragsarbeiter aus
mosambik den opfern von damals gibt
hoyerswerda heute namen gesichter und
geschichten
sie heißen alberto magento francisco
pauli not schavan oder david marco der
heute aus mosambik wieder nach
hoyerswerda reiste und sich erinnert
da waren alle froh in die wir waren
nachbarn verweilen kollege das
haben das habe ich nicht gedacht das war
eine große operation gefallen ist am
anfang seien es etwa 100 jugendliche
gewesen die vor seinem wohnheim
auftauchten und die haben unsere fenster
und tür in der wohnheime kaputt gemacht
und dann alles letzte worte die haben
gesagt wir kommen wieder ich starte die
neue haben das gesagte und
vorbei aber dir sind wir nach reformen
in arbeit der schweizer straße und die
haben alles kaputtgemacht und geblieben
wissen dass wir dann nach hause fliegen
muss
deutlicher konnte ein staat nicht
kapitulieren es sind die opfer die
weichen müssen es sind die täter die
triumphieren und hoyerswerda die stadt
brauchte jahre um worte zu finden
vielleicht auch weil es um die bittere
frage ging wie es dazu kommen konnte
grit lemke hat diese worte gefunden und
niedergeschrieben damals 26 geht sie mit
der stadt und mit sich selbst heute hart
ins gericht wegen der ausschreitungen
und wegen des umgangs damit in den
jahren danach
sicherlich war man erst mal froh dass es
dass das so ein bisschen vorbei war der
ganze albtraum
um vor allen dingen hat sich niemand
gefragt dass es ja auch das was ich mir
und uns heute vorwürfe dass wir nie
gefragt haben was ist denn aus den
geworden die sind raus gebracht worden
wo wohin sind die dann gebracht worden
wie ist denn ihr leben verlaufen das hat
hier überhaupt keine sau interessiert
also das muss man schon sagen keiner
ahnte damals dass hoyerswerda nur den
anfang einer schaurigen serie bilden
sollte die vertreter von rostock mölln
und solingen zeigen dass es ihnen eben
nicht um einzelne städte geht sondern um
die geisteshaltung der 90er in ganz
deutschland nächstes jahr jährt sich
rostock lichtenhagen zum dreißigsten mal
auch dieses gedenken wollen sie dann
gemeinsam beginn
und jetzt nochmal mit wirtschaft das
auftragspolster der deutschen industrie
ist weiter gewachsen das zeigen die
neuen zahlen des statistischen
bundesamtes die nachfrage ist nach dem
corona locker und kräftig gestiegen aber
die produktion ist langsamer angelaufen
auch wegen engpässen etwa bei
halbleitern sina mainitz wie groß ist
das halbleiter problem für die
wirtschaft ja das ist tatsächlich nicht
zu unterschätzen denn dieser mangel an
halbleitern bremst den aufschwung wohl
einfach nicht produziert werden kann
weil die rohstoffe fehlen infineon hätte
den zeitpunkt also für sein heute in
betrieb genommenes werk im
österreichischen villach nicht besser
wählen können die kunden reißen sich um
die chips und davon profitiert das
unternehmen die halbleiter sollen dann
künftig in elektroautos rechenzentren
sowie bei der solar und windenergie
eingesetzt werden der derzeitige mangel
macht vielen branchen zu schaffen
besonders der autoindustrie über 90
prozent der hersteller sind davon
betroffen bis ein stück gefertigt ist
und die fabrik verlässt dauert es monate
tausende arbeitsschritte müssen erfolgen
hochreine schwingungs freie räume sind
dafür nötig infineon lässt sich sein
neues werk 1,6 milliarden euro kosten
bisher kommen die meisten chips aus
südostasien viele spezialisten sitzen
dort und bisher nicht in mitteleuropa
der chip mangel wird die industrie also
noch einige zeit beschäftigen
ein ende dieser engpässe ist derzeit
noch nicht absehbar dieser
rohstoffmangel belastet auch den
deutschen aktienmarkt der dax verliert
am ende der woche rund 1 prozent zum
schluss ein stand von 15.000 490 punkten
am kommenden montag wird der deutsche
aktienindex aufgestockt nach 33 jahren
mit 30 werten vergrößert er sich dann
auch 40 unternehmen die in der ersten
börsenliga gelistet sein werden sina
mainitz fiel dank gerne
das bergwerk in gorleben als mögliches
atommüll-endlager im gespräch war wird
endgültig geschlossen das teilte das
bundesumweltministerium mit der grund
geologische menge jahrzehntelang hatten
die pläne im niedersächsischen gorleben
eine deponie für atommüll einzurichten
teils heftige proteste ausgelöst nun
sollen die stollen des ehemaligen
bergwerks wieder mit salz gefüllt werden
wer sein elektroauto an öffentlichen
ladesäulen auflädt kann in zukunft
häufiger mit der karte bezahlen der
bundesrat stimmte einer verordnung zu
nach der ab juli 2023 in allen neuen
ladepunkte lesegeräte für gängige debit
oder kreditkarten eingebaut sein müssen
das laden von elektroautos soll so
einfacher und unabhängiger werden bisher
setzten die vielen verschiedenen
betreiber der ladesäulen häufig auf
eigene bezahlmethoden wie apps oder
kundenkarten
unter dem motto take control hat
großbritannien die ausschließliche
verwendung alter gewichts einheiten wie
pfund und unzen erlaubt dragset anhänger
bejubelten die rückkehr zu
traditionellen maßangaben diese durften
unter eu regeln nicht allein verwendet
werden der streit um die angaben war
bereits anfang der 2000er jahre anlass
für hitzige debatten in großbritannien
experten warnen vor den neuen regeln die
zum durcheinander und fehlern in der
umrechnung führen könne
und gerade kommt noch eine nachricht
dass frankreich seine botschafter aus
den usa und australien zurück ruft das
ist in der welt der diplomatie ein
äußerst ungewöhnlicher vorgang und hängt
mit an geplatzten u boot geschäft
zusammen darüber wird sicherlich den
nächsten tagen noch mehr berichtet
werden so jetzt konvention
politbarometer das neue politbarometer
haben wir in unserer sendung ja schon
mehrfach angesprochen und neben den
sonntagsfragen hat die forschungsgruppe
wahlen auch noch viele andere
interessante fragen gestellt alle zahlen
und ergebnisse jetzt von matthias
fornoff
guten abend willkommen zum
politbarometer
der countdown läuft neun tage noch bis
zur bundestagswahl die kanzlerkandidaten
abend rielle hinter sich bürgerforen und
klartext arenen die parteien und ihre
programme sind im dauert check es ist
die heiße phase des wahlkampfes es gilt
potenzielle unterstützer zu mobilisieren
aber in der projektion bewegt sich fast
nichts im vergleich zur vorwoche wenn
schon am nächsten sonntag bundestagswahl
wäre dann bliebe die union mit 22
prozent in ihrem rekordtief die spd wäre
mit 25 prozent weiter stärkste kraft die
afg bei 11% fdp ebenfalls elf die linke
6 die grünen kämen auf 16 prozent minus
dass ihre wahlentscheidung jetzt sicher
ist sagen 62 prozent der befragten ganz
ähnlich sah das vor der letzten
bundestagswahl im september 2017 aus im
vergleich zeigt sich aber auch ein
grosser unterschied denn für nur 17
prozent der deutschen ist schon heute
klar wer die bundestagswahl gewinnen
wird 82 prozent sehen weiter ein offenes
rennen vor vier jahren hielten eine
woche vor der wahl 57 prozent den
ausgang schon für entschieden und nur 41
prozent meinten das sei noch offen
für die deutschen ist derzeit der
klimawandel mit großem abstand das
wichtigste problem
erst danach folgt die korona krise und
recht abgeschlagen themen wie
integration soziales gefälle oder rente
themen die die befragten generell
wichtig finden müssen aber nicht
unbedingt die themen sein die den
ausschlag geben für die eigene
wahlentscheidung
denn da geben 53 prozent der befragten
an dass das thema soziale gerechtigkeit
für sie persönlich sehr wichtig sei bei
der stimmabgabe über den klimaschutz
sagen dass noch 43 prozent deutlich
weniger beim thema flüchtlinge und
asylsuchende
von profitieren scholz und die spd wer
hätte noch vor zwei monaten gedacht dass
kandidat und partei an derartigen
aufschwung erleben würden rund zwei
drittel der deutschen halten stolz für
kanzlertauglich ähnlich viele traumes
laschet und bernburg nicht zu
auch der direktvergleich der
kontrahenten hier im verlauf seit juni
zeigt klar scholz hat sich als favorit
herauskristallisiert und die führende
position behauptet
48 prozent hätten am liebsten ihn als
nächsten kanzler nur 22% armin laschet
und 15% annalena baerbock
bei den zehn wichtigsten politikerinnen
und politikern gibt es derzeit wenig
bewegung hier unsere top ten sortiert
nach sympathie und leistung auf der
skala von +5 bis -5
schlusslicht armin laschet minus 0,4
etwas besser davor friedrich merz minus
0,3 deutlich schlechter platz acht für
heiko maas 0,0 jens spahn 0,0 beide mit
leichten verlusten auf platz sechs
annalena baerbock 0,1 davor christian
lindner 0,4 beide etwas besser markus
söder 1,2 robert habeck 1,2 und auf
platz 2 olaf scholz 1,6 und an der
spitze angela merkel 2,4 alle
unverändert
schauen wir noch mal auf die
parteienlandschaft und darauf was an
regierungsbündnissen möglich wäre für
ein zweierbündnis würde es sehr knapp
reichen die neuauflage der großen
koalition unter spd-führung und es wären
verschiedenste dreier bündnisse möglich
etwa rot-grün-rot jamaika oder auch ein
bündnis von spd grünen und fdp das
fänden 37 prozent gut und 39 prozent
schlecht für die spd-geführte neuauflage
der grossen sich 34 prozent erwärmen und
45 prozent nicht ein jamaika-bündnis
eine große koalition unter cdu-führung
und rot-grün-rot lehnt jeweils mehr als
die hälfte der deutschen ab
die spd hält momentan die trümpfe in der
hand sollten die mehrheitsverhältnisse
so bleiben kann sie nach der wahl
partner zum regieren suchen bei den
spd-anhängern zeichnen sich dabei
präferenzen ab 60 prozent fänden grüne
und fdp als partner gut eine mehrheit
von 54 prozent findet auch eine große
koalition gut bei rot grün rot sind die
anhänger der spd eher gespalten
noch aber wird intensiv um stimmen
gekämpft und da der anteil der
briefwählerinnen und wähler rekordhöhen
erreichen wird ist eigentlich jeder tag
ein weiter
das war unser bericht über die stimmung
im land die grafiken und alle
informationen zu unseren umfragen finden
sie wie immer im zdf text ab seite 165
in der zdf- heute- app und oft zdf
heute.de wie die repräsentativen
umfragen der forschungsgruppe wahlen
zustande kommen informationen zur
methodik und zu den qualitätsstandards
finden sie unter politbarometer punkt
zdf.de
vielen dank für ihr interesse das letzte
politbarometer vor der bundestagswahl
sehen sie am donnerstag den 23 september
im heute journal nach dem wetter geht es
hier weiter mit der heute-show ihnen
noch einen entspannten abend auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]
und herzlich willkommen zum wetter ja
die geschichte in der sich unser wetter
abspielt es gerade mal 20 kilometer hoch
ja unter diese schicht hat sich ja immer
weiter auf unter das was wir hier sehen
ist die gesamte atmosphäre von der
internationalen raumstation aus gesehen
was sie hier grünlich schimmern sehen
das sind die polarlichter ein
wunderbarer anblick auf unserem planeten
schauen wir auf dem planeten weiter
unten und zwar sehen wir die drucke
bildung und vor das hoch hier was sich
etabliert hat hält dieses tiefe gefangen
und beide zusammenschieben hier die
kühlen und luft nach deutschland und im
süden kommt warme luft an und so wird es
sogar fast ein sommertag morgen geben
schauen wir erstmal in die nachts da
gibt es viele wolken die von nordwesten
reinziehen regen ist auch dabei nach
südwesten hin bildet sich nebel ganz im
süden lockert es auf und die sterne
funkeln dazu temperaturen von 14 grad an
der ostsee im süden deutlich kühler
einstellig und an den alpen 6 grad
morgen im tagesverlauf weiter im
nordosten viele worten teils regen an
der elbe und richtung erzgebirge ganz im
süden ganz viel sonnenschein also
anrecht freundlicher tag dort und das
bei höchsten temperaturen bis 24 grad im
südwesten
und 15 16 grad zb an der ostsee die
kommenden tage am sonntag vor allem im
süden durchwachsen mit schauern und bis
21 grad am montag wird es trockener aber
nicht mehr ganz so warm sein damit ein
schöner abend